hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger on
today I'll be working on a small church
which is going to stand on top of the
mountain in the middle of the Rhine and
really be the centerpiece of the ride
but also be working on some general
scenery stuff so I'll be getting to an
Iron Bridge which the cursor is going to
go over and also do some general scenery
now as you can see I've already laid out
where the church is going to be since
this is very heavily focused on the
sight lines so this episode itself I'm
going to do a lot of detailing so
without further ado let's get into it
all right now I'm beginning the
time-lapse with the section of the
church since this is really going to be
the signature parts of the ride I would
pretty much say this is the Rini of the
right although very carefully because
there's quite a bit of force perspective
and sight lines in general on the
mountains as a whole that I wouldn't
want to call this building in particular
the Rena but I'd rather call the entire
mountain the scenery centerpiece of the
ride but the reason that this church in
general is so important to this ride and
why I'm building this church
specifically is because I think it just
signifies the theme really well the idea
behind the theme of this coaster is that
it's somewhat different from your
standard mind train and I'm using a very
much sort of Belle Epoque kind of Alpine
Switzerland being to this and I'll
definitely flesh that out more in future
I've already got lots of ideas on this
but it's a bit of an unique theme in
that sense but it's generally it's very
Alpine esque so I really wanted to give
a European look to this right and well
normally if you would go for a
centerpiece like this you'd very
commonly see something like a castle or
just a simple big rock I think I didn't
want to go with that because it doesn't
really signify the theme as much as one
of these typical Alpine churches that
you see out there in the Alps are so the
design and the placement of this
building in general is very much
inspired by all of these small churches
that you see in Austria and Switzerland
or southern Germany and it has that same
baroque similar sort of onion dome style
to it which also made it kind of
difficult to make this church but I
think it really does give you that
idea I'm like instantly taking you into
this Alps area and I almost feel as if
you know if it weren't for this church
it could have been any mountain range
anywhere in the world and the theming
wouldn't be so specific and wouldn't be
so unique to this ride and so even if
this church isn't the best looking idea
for this position certainly a very
unusual one for theme parks I think it
is pretty important for setting the
theme of this coaster and the general
atmosphere even so my idea for the
design of the church is really simple I
didn't want to go with a lot of towers
or anything and I didn't want to go for
a very large building either in fact I
met this building purposely small but
that's something I'll get into later I
wanted to really emulate the standard
baroque kind of churches that you find
around the Alps and although there are a
few twists around it you won't see too
much of that for the tower here but
basically what I did and I skipped a
little bit of making the top work there
I refined the colors a bit that that was
actually my main issue with this I built
one tower before this one that was pink
with white and I was extremely unhappy
with that so decided to build this one
instead with different colors but even
then I changed it I really wanted some
muted colors that wouldn't be too
colorful and kind of go along with the
environments while at the same time not
being too boring
but anyway what made this pretty
difficult but also very striking is the
spire on top of the tower because these
buildings very commonly have these onion
spires which are these rounded spine
instead pretty much look like an onion
it's not that they're layered anything
or oil I think they technically are but
they're spires in the shape of an onion
but growing even further than that you
have some very decorated baroque expires
around these areas in that that was
something that I really wanted to try
and emulate with this build so with this
spire was the major pain in making this
build work since it's a quite a bit of
work to generally make the spire work at
first it kind of goes from a four-sided
Tower and transitions into a
spire with well eight sides if I'm doing
the math correctly now that's the other
day right and so it transitions
basically into an octagon spider and it
has like that small ball sort of onion
shaped thing in the middle and ending up
with like a small peak going into that
golden decoration it's not exactly the
design that I based on any existing
Church I just compiled a lot of pictures
of all kinds of baroque churches all
over Austria and Switzerland and kind of
took a mix from that since there are
some very simple spires that consist of
just one of these little onion shapes
and they're all there are also some very
like ridiculous spires that have all
kinds of different shapes and are
extremely tall and even have like a
small cupola in the top of them and I
sort of wanted to go for an in-between
route so this is definitely a bit of a
mismatch spire in that sense but it's
something that I'm actually pretty glad
with in the end since I didn't want the
spires and they're becoming too big
since the building itself is actually
quite small so yeah it's in a sense it's
not as a complex spire as a clip in but
it was still pretty complex to build and
it's very very heavily relies on that
method where you basically make one part
of it then rotate that around to finish
that part off and then once I had like a
quarter of the spire that way I just
have to finish it and copy that around
and that's pretty much the entire spire
just like that so we have a custom roof
on the top of the tower but I also
wanted to have a custom roof on the side
of the building I hope because I just
wanted to be a hipster like that but
just because I wasn't really too happy
with any given roofs that you get in the
game and because I secretly didn't want
to make the textures match between the
two and I would just feel really
frustrated frustrated if my tower had a
different style roof than the rest of my
building had so I decided to take the
same wooden pieces and basically make a
roof out of it and another issue was
that the in-game roots are
too big so I would have had to make
things a little bit more complex anyway
and that basically is due to the fact
that this building is very small and I
want to explain this very quickly
because I said I would basically this
building is smaller than a full tile
you'll notice that I built the tower out
of window pieces instead of actual war
pieces because the tower is actually
much smaller than a full tile on their
own any half tile walls in the game and
the windows to make walls kind of method
has been popularized by free the bear
and fo with their Teleco project i just
wanted to shout this out because it's
one of my favorite projects you should
check it out in the description it's a
really cool coaster but yeah anyway they
made that a very popular sort of method
and I really wanted to try my hand at it
again here and basically it allowed me
to make this building smaller than the
actual buildings in the game are because
this building I wanted to make it look
as if it's really big even though it's
extremely small and that's kind of where
the force perspective comes into play
you might know that if you look for
instance at many Disney buildings in the
main street or the castle and min of the
parks the further you go up the smaller
the floors become and you might notice
that like especially in the original
Disney Land the upper floors of the
course were actually extremely small and
I wanted to do something similar with
this building so this building is
actually very downscaled it's much too
small for the regular scale or even a
human scale and planet coaster and it'll
definitely be in a wrong scale compared
to all of the other buildings that are
going to be in the park so that kind of
helps to make the entire book look a
little bit bigger and it kind of helps
to make this building look a bit further
apart from the past so you might also
notice that I didn't put anything
directly next to this building it's
really standing alone on that tall rock
and you can't really come close to it
with the path or with the coaster so
it's it's it still kind of feels as if
it's this far away church building on
top of the mountain really kind of
towering over everything else when in
reality this is actually a pretty tiny
building so yeah that was just a bit of
force perspective
and it's more nuance than just that but
I don't think the time map is good
enough to really show how that works
exactly so I'll just kind of continue I
make the size of the building here and I
completely forgot the name of these
gothic elements that supports the size
of the walls but basically they're one
of these old gothic elements and this is
also where the building is a bit of a
mix of different styles I guess since
the tower is pretty Baroque but then
this is a really sort of gothic addition
and the overall idea for this park in
terms of the theme is that it's a Swiss
style park and that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's in Switzerland it
probably would be that's where I would
place the coaster but it's Swiss style
in the sense that the Swiss style is a
style that was very popular around the
19th to 20th century and there are many
things to explain about the style unlike
many small details about it but it's a
very sort of intricate style with lots
of ornamental details it's a bit like I
guess it's a bit like Belle Epoque
except for alpine architecture and it
was pretty popular around Central Europe
in the time and there's even been some
buildings in America with the style and
it's something that I really thought I'd
give a try for this park because I
wanted to make an Alpine Park but I've
done that way too many times or an
Alpine Coaster I guess but I wanted to
do it with a twist
so it's not something like I've done too
many times already but it's it's in a
different way so you'll see a bit more
of that as well but it does mean that
this building over here even though it's
a church and it's inspired by the
baroque churches of the Alps it does
have some random influences from all
kinds of places and a lot from that
Swiss style as well now the sides of the
building here and also the small
staircase that I'm working on are almost
finished I wanted to give it this small
staircase because otherwise I feel the
transition from the door would be super
awkward because it doesn't technically
go anywhere but I still wanted to make
it look as though you could enter the
building and by having a staircase
directly toward the front
you would just kind of have a staircase
leaping toward your death so that wasn't
really ultra great so figured it would
be better to add a small staircase to it
and here I'm adding one of these very
typical Swiss style influence elements
to it with the gables on the side of the
roof here being pretty ornamentally
detailed and and I'm not even sure about
all of the technical names for it
but what a lot of these Swiss style
buildings have is they've got these
wooden ornaments on the front of their
Gables and that's something that I
really wanted to test out here over as
well it's something that's pretty
interesting because the wooden pieces
that are supposed to be per pillars that
I'm not too sure how often have actually
used them for pillars they're super good
for making all kinds of very small
details especially if you're building a
bridge anyway and you can use them for
the things that you using them for so
over here decided to make the cable
decorations with them there aren't
really many or any gable decorations in
the game so I thought that would be
interesting to mess with so I made it
mostly out of those wooden pieces and a
few Christmas decorations thrown into
the mix just to make it a bit more
decorative but then I kind of thought it
was over the top so I removed a few of
those and the rest is just trying to
cover up the ugly and like roof tiles
that I made just to make it look as if
there was like a proper custom roof over
there the easy thing of course is that
you can just copy over this thing to the
other side I had to repair a couple of
things but other than that it's pretty
much directly copied over to the other
side and again I don't exactly know any
of the names of like technical names for
instance I've noticed that a lot of the
Chalet style buildings have the sort of
cross of wood on the fronts with a
wooden post sticking out on top of the
roof they're like these little features
that I noticed across the style that I
thought I'd put into the building that
I'm not too sure what they're actually
called or anything but that's really
what my inspiration is strong I don't
want to make this look too usual because
I don't think there's really
as much creativity in trying to
completely emulate something that's
existing so that's something I wanted to
avoid also it was pretty sweet to make
that round window using the wooden
pieces like like I just said I guess you
can literally make anything out of these
pieces and I put a gothic window in the
back and then just kind of shaped the
rest of the wall around that using
Windows so yeah there's there's even a
lot that you can do with the window
pieces as walls because it gives you a
lot more flexibility than if you're
using the in-game walls which is a great
argument to make to actually get to
start using Windows as walls the only
problem is of course that they do cost
quite a bit of game performance and also
quite some time but yeah I think it's
pretty sweet and just to finish the
entire thing up I wanted to put some
wooden decorations well they're not
decorations they're actually just
supports on the side and I think that's
just about it for the building yeah I'm
still going to add a few windows to it
if I haven't added those already but the
rest is really just trying to add some
rock work and foliage on the side to
kind of make it blend in with the rest I
wasn't really too sure what I wanted to
do with the foliage on top of the rock
here since I obviously didn't want to
obscure the church and I also really
wanted to make it look as if it was the
top of the mountain so everything is
really low but at the same time I didn't
want to just make it completely barren
so it's just a lot of bushes and stuff
it's also the one thing where I see all
that realism is broken a little bit
because realistically you would want to
have like some sort of concrete opening
or something on top of the mountain
something that is at least Bank stage
esque but I'll see how I can put that in
there there's definitely a small point
on top of the mountain where I can add
some backstage details that you don't
actually see
now the church is pretty much finished
at this point so I wanted to go into the
second big thing of this video which is
the bridge for the coaster here so this
is obviously something that is well
straight ripped off from every mind
train in existence at least I guess big
grizzly because it has a really cool
bridge but Expedition Everest also has
that very interesting lift Hill bridge
and well there is a very common kind of
feature in any case it's something that
I want to try here because I thought it
would look really interesting and
obviously it gives you some interaction
with like lower and higher levels of the
coaster which is really interesting and
it gives some very interesting stuff to
look at from the path plus it's like a
really cool sight line if you're
standing on the path and you kind of
have the person viewing this helix in
front of you then behind that you kind
of have the bridge going over the roller
coaster track and yet again behind that
you see the church kind of looming up on
that rock it just makes everything look
a little bit further away when in
reality on the part you're understanding
like 50 meters away from the church so
yeah that was my idea here but of course
I also just wanted to make a fancy
bridge and experiment with that a bit
because I don't think I've ever really
built an Iron Bridge like this I mean
Boneshaker might count a little bit but
I was just still using some in-game old
pieces that we had at the time say this
with some very interesting
experimentation with the in-game iron
pieces to see what you can make out of
them although I have to be honest at
first I try to do it using the wooden
pieces and then I replace them with the
iron pieces here but my mistake at the
time is to make the iron pieces
completely pitch black and I don't feel
it quite works so well since apparently
for these pieces pitch black really does
mean pitch black and as a general rule
of thumb at least one I always try to do
is to avoid using black or white as like
pure colors
if it's possible in an object to make
something pitch-black or completely 100%
white
you should pretty much avoid it at all
times because there's just no way that
can realistically look all right in any
kind of setting like actual white always
looks very glaringly lighter than
everything around it so you want to go
with something that's not quite white
and with the black of the metal at first
I also felt that was extremely dark so I
kind of made that very dark gray and I
think it works quite nicely what I also
wanted to add was some basic decorations
around the top of the bridge tip of
course I didn't want to have something
to look at while you're in the mine
train although I didn't want to cover
the bridge with a roof this is a pretty
common and interesting looking thing
which I might experiment with later on
I'm actually not too sure but I didn't
want to do it here because there's just
too importance of the sight line over
the bridge here and I just wanted to
have the bridge as a part of the
landscape but not really blocking and in
use so I wanted to keep that quite
simple and here finally I had to work on
the helix so we're getting it through
stairs again
now I measured this out in the middle of
doing miss parts because I was slightly
worried I'm worried about how this would
actually work because basically these
are the evacuation stairs and you want
to be able to actually be able to climb
onto these stairs but a lot of the
stairs
some people have commented in the park
are still very low so it isn't quite a
comfortable step to get out of the
coasters and or get out of the coaster
and also the stairs at some point which
is definitely an issue so I just quickly
have the Train beside the stairs there
for a minute actually seems quite all
right over here especially with the
Train sort of being banked toward the
middle this is just about the level
where you're going to get out of the
cars so it's a pretty comfortable place
to get out of the car if you need to so
that's what we're doing here which is
really just for evacuation purposes but
because they're so common in real life
for evacuation purposes I also wanted to
realistically have them here and of
course I think they just look fancy so
we're getting those in
and I also wanted to work on the side of
the rock here a little bit obviously
everything sort of has to be interesting
I didn't want to just make this coaster
a bunch of mountains with rocks and
foliage and the stairs kind of helped to
mitigate that sort of boringness but
also want to wanted to try and mess
around with a little bit more
decorations around the side of the cosa
Trek and especially how I support the
coaster because I think supporting
without actually building any coaster
supports will be a very fun challenge
and something that I definitely want to
try so what I wanted to try here was to
build these Apple and these I can't
speak English today sorry about that
these ever launch barriers which is
something that of course you do see
pretty often in areas like this and I
think it might as well be something to
support the coasters drink with and also
kind of make it like invisible a little
bit from the pot but I just really
didn't like the way that it was cheekily
overhanging over the rocks so I think
this works out a little bit better it's
also a bit of a makeshift
course during that in a sense that if
people are going to throw stuff out of
the coaster over there in the turn it's
not going to really hit anyone in the
ground because there are these sort of
coaster net ethic things on the side so
I guess that kind of helps as well but
it also just means that we don't just
have to look at a boring book which
looks like every single book but there's
actually like some in theme protection
and screening and support for the
coaster
so yeah that was my little idea like
that
there's definitely all kinds of
different wooden stuff that you can
feature in a theme like this
so we'll see what else we can do in the
future but for now I think this is
pretty fun idea that I might even just
put some random at lunch barriers on the
side of the mountain at some point they
bickered look pretty neat so I'm here on
the side I'm just adding some of the
foliage to finish everything up I've
started using a little bit more soil
because I did realize that it's not
really too realistic to have grass
everywhere you can definitely grow kinds
of grass and bushes on artificial rocks
like these
but you're going to have to blend some
soil and there are just some areas where
you're not going to have any grass grow
especially around the coaster here so I
make that some soil ground texture
instead of grass there and I think it
works out very nice actually I think it
looks a lot better than grass not just a
bit more realistic but it's also nicer
to have that sort of soil texture and
put some bushes in the middle of that
than to just have grass everywhere that
said I will keep the rock textures like
this these the rooks the color of the
rocks as unusual as they might be seems
every mine train somehow manages to have
like beige brown ash rocks I'm going to
keep the colors of the rocks like this
because this is just the way that works
in the outlook and I think it just kind
of helped it kind of helps give the the
coaster a bit more of that unique look
that most mine trains don't have so yeah
I know I can't even experiment much with
that because there aren't any other
different types of rock textures in
whose biomes yeah we're pretty much
stuck with this now I'm finishing up the
time-lapse here with a little bit of
rock work to finish up the section here
so that we have one big theme section
that I can make a thumbnail out of but
really that's almost it I just put some
shrubbery and some rock work on the side
here I'm still kind of trying to figure
out how to blend the rocks with the
Indian rock texture because they do
blend alright and I'm trying to keep the
rocks and that's slightly more
artificial look to them but it's still
quite difficult to get that down exactly
like the transition between the rocks
and the soil it's hard to make it very
artificial here but yeah within your
foliage you don't really notice it too
much and you know at some point in the
future maybe you will find a decent fix
for that anyway that's just about it for
this episode of Jaeger horn so thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
guys the next episode
[Music]
[Music]